welcome to this video playing black man
so let's go for a very solid Queens
gambit declined him maybe place the
Catalan yeah he does I don't really have
a good antidote against that move that
opening after admit that play various
things but they never really feel like I
know what I'm doing this is at least
fairly solid
Knight to e5 here mmm do I go 97 here
immediately or not yeah maybe stabilize
the center a little bit and then then
play 97
hmm interesting he has that efore idea
but not not immediately i may be foimd
for so that's not working can I go D for
here or it's that bad idea night it's 94
an issue
hmm interesting t form
and take on see form taking on c4 is
definitely a risky move 94 to the six
things like that what about be five set
to move be five that's an interesting
idea let's try it it gives me queen bee
six check and possibly be form kicking
the night away
okay so i may give the check now or I
take it and plank Knight b6 is that an
idea for a night coming to be four maybe
somehow this has a dish of kind of
feeling to it and I to be six in the
scale of position just like I had this
in a game not too long ago hmm and
usually those déjà Vu's they are not
with with the positive experiences but
anyway anyway let's see what happens hb5
maybe my bishop on b7 is unprotected
that's not great but still can not be
five is not a problem I have Bishop a
six yeah right that should be okay
really
so Queen hiya Quincy 795 is a tempo he's
not threatening to take any way on b6 I
mean because of Bishop c5 check with
Queen d 7 i'm preparing night c4
shouldn't be bad not c4 ok maybe he may
be place efore then i can also consider
rook c4e for groups eh this kind of
thing maybe I'm kind of switching around
ideas here oh he had Bishop takes b6 and
Quincy form I just spotted that we have
other lucky that was lucky he was mostly
seeing my idea and was not thinking what
positively and what positive things had
changed for him well it was a very lucky
mordion so Bishop a is 6
ok
snide a4a move he takes Queen takes I
have to keep Bishop everyone also in
mind that is in there maybe maybe this
is still okay Knight takes rook cheeks
and then maybe Bishop c4 interesting
yeah that seems kind of okay
one minute 50 year in terms of my rating
currently in the five-minute pmos
hovering around the to 350 so I don't
feel I'm not quite where I was
constantly being on 2,400 plus but at
least I'm fairly steady around that
level I don't know what it is I would
definitely had some signs of of
rustiness after my break but also might
beat you due to some changes in my diet
that affect my play I'm not quite sure
it definitely affects your play of you
if you change something there but how to
tell so about equal time and an
interesting position yeah that's sharp
huh that's a sharp move I can take now
however and Bishop c5 isn't that a
problem let's do it main problem being
this move here no no my queen is all of
a sudden the was deciding factor yeah
that was a London eform but it was very
lucky he had one moment where he could
simply win the game let's check around
him yeah I'm playing this closed set up
here against the Catalan and I
interesting Nigel why not yeah that's
true that's given by the computer and it
doesn't see how I'm not winning that
pawn the big point is that i have a
check nasty check here ha that was much
better so that's already a mistake b5 is
the engine move that
scoot went here and now this idea I
don't think it's bad so interesting way
to play rook c8 maybe Bishop 86 first
would have been better but ok around
here I think we added talking about an
ok equal ish kind of position but this
is just a thought blunder I thought that
he can do this yeah I can so okay I
actually have to okay that's why the
computer that's not giving class free or
something because I can actually give up
the exchange him and this is this is
actually not so clear I mean of course
wide it's much better with the exchange
but I get the Bishop to c5 and that
would be a very strong piece the engine
is just on 0.6 year not not a complete
win still I was just blundering him and
he could have taken could have fun use
that gym that's all seems very normally
and that losers he has to do something
conservative probably the engine wants
to play this I felt like I'm a bit
better maybe because of them um because
of my somewhat safer looking king and my
piece is a bit more active that Bishop
is not doing much King g7 is given by
the engine 0.6 0.7 for luck yeah they
pawn maybe is something that I can win
or trying to coordinate something
against this king it's not fantastically
good for black but probably a bit better
that that might be true okay well thanks
for watching